time now for defending the first series
where we expose the enemies of the First
Amendment free expression and free
thought now they pay played a role in 54
victories in front of the Supreme Court
and have defended families and marriage
but now they're being targeted by forces
on the left in an effort to blunt their
effectiveness the conservative Alliance
defending freedom was targeted by this
disgusting billboard campaign in New
York City's Times Square Kaleb Cade a
spokesman for the group behind the
campaign defended this smear saying
quote we want to remind people that
there are still really insidious forces
at work against our community
ADF has been leading that war for a long
time here there now to respond Gerry
Majesco senior counsel for Alliance
defending freedom Jeremy I have a gay
brother I love him very much so I didn't
like that sign at all I thought it was
hideous
that was a group opposing your group
what's going on here well look atf that
the science preposterous ADF is the most
successful respected Supreme Court
advocate in the country on First
Amendment rights
we've won nine cases in the last seven
years in front of the US Supreme Court
and that's really only a snapshot of our
work we've also won 400 victories on
college campuses protecting students
free speech rights on campus we defend
churches all the time against
discriminatory policies that exclude
them from benefits and programs simply
because their religious churches
religious institutions and so our work
is broad in scope we do a lot of great
work we protect everybody's freedom so
your point in the cases involving the
gay movement would be religious freedom
cases is that right yeah those are
religious freedom they're really
compelled speech cases and you know
their ad is completely misrepresents
everything our case is a sandy area they
want they want to get people's attention
and look they got mine right and our you
know our clients serve everyone so the
people we represent in those cases are
creative professional clients they serve
everyone
they just can't create art promoting
every message and that's the most
important thing Jack Phillips we just
win his case at the Supreme Court as a
cake artist he declined to create a cake
celebrating a same-sex marre would you
represent a gay group if their first
amendment rights were being violated
well absolutely we would we support the
rights of everybody our wins our wins
and now that because when we have
represented gay clients
we but we represent people from all
faiths as well and so it's really
important to understand that when we win
cases we win them for everybody the free
speech and free exercise and conscience
rights rights we protect our rights that
we all benefit from the Southern Poverty
Law Center figures in here because
they've branded you a hate group and
they've put people like me and other
conservative commentators on hit lists
which are really despicable as
anti-muslim forces it's just despicable
things that they've done and people here
Southern Poverty Law Center they think
oh that's the gold standard of civil
rights organizations and I think sadly
that's not true but I want to put up a
graphic they have a lot of money total
assets four hundred seventy seven
million endowment you see it there for
thirty two they do a big as you told me
during the break they have big mail mail
solicitations they get a lot of money
from that but how are they involved here
well this group the Citizens for
transparency actually a very secretive
group you really can't find anything
about that sign right they put up the
side they're just parroting the Southern
Poverty Law Center's misinformation
about us the Southern Poverty Law Center
has been discredited for decades by
investigative journalists charity
watchdogs commentators what they do is
they attack people who disagree with
their farlow conservatives it's an
attempt to intimidate people absolutely
from expressing themselves like we want
more speech in this country I like the
fact that we have a First Amendment for
people of all backgrounds political
backgrounds religious sexual orientation
have your voice respect to each other in
your conversation but the idea of
intimidating people but I know that I
can intimidate you you guys have had a
pretty darn good record at the court
they're not and what we'd like this
group to do is come out of the woodwork
let's have a conversation let's debate
the issues don't hide behind secrecy
don't be anonymous come out and let's
have a debate about the issues we're
happy to do that well it's great to have
you on thanks so much Jeremy